[Musique]
je suis heureux d'être ici parce que ici
ce strasbourg à les excès une ville qui
s'est libérée c'est une vie qui s'est
libérée elle se libérer de quoi première
ville en france à avoir piétonniser son
centre ville dès les années 70
première ville en france à avoir
réintroduit le tramway dès les années 90
première ville en france la place du
vélo dans son quotidien
en fait première ville en france à voir
libérer son centre-ville de ses voitures
et avoir posé cette question à ses
habitants une question veut provocante
finalement pouvez vous vous passer de
votre voiture
pouvez-vous vous vous passer de votre
voiture
on va faire un sondage est ce que ceux
qui dans la salle n'ont pas de voitures
peuvent s'il vous plaît lever la main ok
alors j'ai pas tout mais il ya une bonne
nouvelle et il ya une moins bonne
nouvelle loi conçue par la bonne
nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que il ya quand
même beaucoup de mains qui se lèvent et
ça ce que ça montre c'est ce qu'on lit
dans les rapports c'est vrai c'est que
ici plus qu'ailleurs on utilise le vélo
pour se déplacer ici moins qu'ailleurs
on utilise la voiture pour se déplacer
se faisaient même la une des journaux il
ya quelques jours et malgré ça il ya
également bonne nouvelle c'est que même
ici même à strasbourg
même dans ce laboratoire reconnu partout
en europe pour ses avancées en termes de
mobilité
même ici il ya beaucoup de mains qui ne
se lève pas et au fond au fond moi je
comprends parce qu'objectivement si vous
êtes à brumath
mais c'est pas non plus hyper facile de
vivre sans sa voiture et se consacre ce
fonds ceux qui n'ont pas levé la main
ici et se fond dans la région en france
un peu partout et la statistique ine
frappé ses sept français sur 10 qui
disait ne pas pouvoir vivre ne pas
pouvoir se passer de leur voiture
je sais pas pour vous mais moi c'est moi
et m'ont frappé les mots ont un sens ne
pas pouvoir se passer
moi ça m'évoque dessins évoquent la
dépendance ça m'évoque la dépendance un
peu comme si notre voiture était devenu
un membre de plus un peu encombrant et
c'est le cas en france mais partout
finalement dans le monde et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a 2 milliards de
véhicules sur la planète et moi ça
m'interpelle moi je le demande mais ça
ça va coûter combien ça coûte chine et
ça coûte et combien c'est quoi le coup
aujourd'hui pour ma société pour ma
communauté mais aussi pour ma vie à moi
est le premier coup mais c'est
évidemment ce qui se produit quand ils
utilisent cette voiture c'est le stress
et le temps passé dans la voiture dans
les embouteillages
c'est la congestion et la pollution moi
je vais vous faire une confidence j'ai
toujours été très sensible aux enjeux
environnementaux mais finalement je me
suis rendu compte récemment que c'était
un peu conceptuel en approche
je voyais les jt sur tf1 et france 2 et
je voyais ces images de ville archi
polluer avec des gens qui se baladent
avec un masque et moi je disais mais
j'espère qu'un jour si j'ai des enfants
ils viendront pas et qu'un masque c'est
un peu comme ça que j'approchais mais au
fond de moi au fond moi il ya une petite
voix qui me disait inquiète alex tai en
france et c'est pas ici et maintenant
que l'urgence allait prégnante
c'est long et j'en parlais avec un ami
parce que lui aussi avait un peu cette
approche conceptuelle et il a arrêté
d'avoir deux sont constitués le jour où
il a déménagé il vivait boulevard
magenta en plein paris à quelques
minutes à pied de la gare du nord très
embouteillé pour ceux qui connaissent et
il avait déménagé en banlieue à boulogne
il me dit tiens c'est marrant parce que
comme par hasard du jouant demain j'ai
plus besoin de vous emmener mes enfants
chez le médecin à trois par mois comme
par hasard
du jour au lendemain je suis plus
fatigué quand je rentre après le boulot
et j'ai un peu d'énergie pour faire des
choses quand je rentre du boulot et en
fait je me suis dit en l'écoutant meiway
aujourd'hui on parle pas des masques là
ce soir a priori personne entre nous à
porter des masques pourtant c'est bien
ici et maintenant et dans nos corps
convoi
les premiers des faits il le pire jeu
bien c'est qu'on parle que de 4% des
problèmes à 4%
je vais faire deux sondages mais c est
quand même de devenir de deviner ce que
ça peut être 4 % 4 % c'est le taux
d'utilisation de notre voiture
on achète de voiture on dépense beaucoup
on en parlera après et on les utilise
une heure par jour 4 % et les vingt
trois heures
il faut bien faire quelque chose de sale
voiture alors on la gare à londres c'est
20 % de l'espace immobilier urbain qui
est utilisé pour des places de parking
vraiment construire des tours sas à
chicago ouais vous construire des tours
pour héberger les voitures etc mais ce
patient du mais ceux-ci du temps perdu
c'est ce film dont vous avez loupé le
début parce que au lieu d'être
confortablement installé dans votre
fauteuil cinéma vous étiez au volant de
votre voiture à faire des ronds dans la
ville à chercher une place de parking
et puisqu'on parle puisqu'on parle de
coups mais moi je vous pose de finir par
l'addition et elle est salée elle est
salé l'addition
parce que c'était plein de petits coups
c'est quoi ces lamentations du véhicule
c'est les assurances c'est l'été pain et
je veux pas croire une seule personne
c'est qu'il me dirait qu'ils n'aient pas
eu d'ennuis avec son véhicule dans les
12 derniers mois et tout ça c'est 6000
euros par an pour quelque chose qu'on
utilise 4 % du temps alors malgré ça
malgré ce stress cette congestion cette
pollution
ce temps cet argent je sais pas pour
vous mais moi j'ai l'impression que nous
en france mais un peu partout dans le
monde
on adore notre voiture on a un lien
quasi émotionnel avec d'autres voitures
je suis sûr que dans cette salle il y en
a même qui lui donne un petit nom alors
voiture
et rassurez vous je ne veux pas vous le
demander de lever la main j'ai pas envie
de vous mettre mal à l'aise et ce lien
émotionnel il a été longtemps
il est longtemps était rationnel parce
que c'était la liberté
c'était je peux partir là ici maintenant
et des quelques déplacements que je ne
peux pas faire en transport en commun
je peux les faire avec ma voiture ça
c'était vrai pendant longtemps je suis
convaincu que c'est plus vrai
aujourd'hui il ya 20 ans et un nouvel
objet qui arrivait dans nos poches
alors pour moi c'était un peu le rêve
c'était le rutilant nokia 33 10 et jeter
plein de choses avec je peux passer des
coups de fil et parfois je joue un
serpent a été meilleur que mes amis je
vous rassure je fais un peu plus de
choses aujourd'hui avec mon téléphone
portable je l'utilisent pour travailler
pour écouter de la musique
pour réserver un resto parfois même
parfois même en page sur le proche
apparemment pour passer des coups de fil
et depuis peu de temps pour commander
une voiture avec chauffeur
je veux aller au resto je sors mon
téléphone jour l'application un clic et
une voiture arrive en quelques minutes
je suis en retard un rendez vous
important
un clic une voiture vient chercher et
j'y vais son stress et sa clique là il
permet de faire beaucoup de choses
il nous permet de dire à l'application
bonjour je suis alexandre je suis au 1
place dauphine à strasbourg et je veux
aller le plus vite possible à brumath au
numéro de téléphone c'est au 06 75 88 20
54 au numéro de carte bleue c'est le bon
jeu qu'un pas vous donner vous savez que
j'ai un bon payeur et j'ai une bonne
note et l'application elle me répond
très bien
c'est noté c'est noté une voiture arrive
en quelques minutes c'est une box
week-end passat syrie un cheveu
professionnel vient la conduire et il a
une très bonne note utilisateurs
ce dialogue
il ya lieu sur un écran en moins d'une
demi seconde en bien moins de temps que
j'en ai eu besoin pour vous le décrire
et il enclenche un cercle vertueux
ce cercle vertueux c'est quoi c'est
simple et on adore la simplicité plus
d'utilisateurs plus de conducteurs donc
un meilleur maillage - tant attendu pour
les utilisateurs plus d'utiliser encore
plus de conducteurs pour les conducteurs
moins de temps mort entre chaque course
pour les utilisateurs un service
toujours aussi fiable pour les
conducteurs plus de revenus pour les
passagers c'est toujours moins cher et
enfin une alternative crédible à la
voiture individuelle
j'avais sept mille jeunes est qui et
avec qui on en discute et justement j'ai
dû présenter la première fois cette
application parce que moi en fait il ya
quatre ans après six ans en finance à
londres
j'ai changé de cap dans ma vie
professionnelle et j'ai rejoint le
porter
j'ai rejoint une sorte up qui te plaît
qu'il appelle encore über est-ce qu'on
essayait de faire c'était de développer
une application comme ça alors j'ai mon
rôle en fait mon rôle à moi c'était de
lancer en europe au moyen-orient en
afrique je suis beaucoup amusé et j'ai
beaucoup voyagé je me suis beaucoup
douté face à une façon polie de vous
dire que je me suis jamais pris autant
de vestes en aussi peu de temps parce
que partout où j'arrivais dans une
nouvelle ville ce qui se fait c'était la
même chose
j'arrivais je présentais le service
qu'en disaient ouais c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal mais ça honnêtement pas pas ici
pas ici au mieux au mieux vous arriverez
à servir des gens qui veulent rentrer de
soirée et c'est vrai qu'au début c'était
surtout un service qui parlait aux
noctambules pour ce que vous voulez
rentrer de soirée et progressivement
plus que plus que ça il n'avait pu
utiliser pour déménager qui utilisés
pour aller chez le médecin qu'il
utilisait pour emmener leurs enfants à
l'école en fait ils l'utilisaient tout
simplement que mes utilisaient leur
propre voiture a eu pour revenir sur cet
ami lionel m'expliquer justement que lui
il y avait planté sa voiture alors
heureusement
heureusement sans dommage corporel
il disait toi j'ai fait des calculs au
fond je veux vendre acheter
j'ai besoin de racheter une parce que
les transports en commun ça fait 80 %
des déplacements et pour les 20%
restants mais je commande une voiture
avec chauffeur un jour l'autre jour je
loue la voiture d'un particulier
le troisième jour ben je partage un
trajet un peu longue distance et
finalement je m'en tire très bien il dit
alex fais toi cette liste cette liste
ça te liste de tous les trajets
où tu penses que tu as besoin de ta
voiture
je me suis fait cette liste est encore
aujourd'hui j'en ai pas trouvé une seule
de ces occasions où ça ce téléphone
portable ça fait pas la faire je n'ai
toujours pas trouvé une seule l'a
récemment jean ménager dans mon nouvel
appart avec ma femme ou métro blanche à
paris on veut déménager nos meubles
je sors mon téléphone à cliquer et je
loue une voiture qui est à deux pâtés de
maisons moins d'un quart d'heure après
show volant et j'ai cherché les meubles
je veux au mariage d'un bon ami d'école
il ya trois mois ça 100 km de paris je
vais à orléans
orléans est quelqu'un qui l'attend sur
le quai de la gare c'est eric eric c'est
qui eric c'est en particulier que j'ai
rencontrés par un site de location de
particulier à particulier
il ya des supers note de la part des
gens qui ont le malheur sa voiture sa
voiture et coule vraiment pas grand
chose et en plus c'est hyper soupe est
maintenant à la gare
j'ai pris la voiture alors je me fais le
clic et parce que sa voiture était rayé
dans tous les sens mais honnêtement ça
faisait largement la sphère demain vous
voulez aller au boulot à là pour le coup
je pense qu'on est bien servie avec les
transports en commun ils sont en panne
vous pouvez y aller en vélo il fait trop
froid comme aujourd'hui vous pouvez
commander une voiture avec chauffeur
c'est trop cher c'est une voiture avec
chauffeur vous pouvez la partager avec
un autre utilisateur
en fait dont on s'est rendu compte chez
schaeffer c'est que il y avait beaucoup
de trajets qu avait lieu au même moment
sur le même trajet pour se demander
est-ce qu'on peut les partager
est-ce qu'on peut les fusionner ce
trajet on a créé quelque chose qui
rappelle hubert push vous donner un
exemple demain vous vous êtes place de
l'étoile et que vous voulez aller gare
de l'est
vous sortez votre téléphone un clic
quelqu'un arrive le conducteur est
derrière sophie
une passagère elle veut pas la gare de
l'est je veux juste aller à l'opéra mais
c'est sur le chemin vous les déposez
vous y rêver quelques minutes après
c'est confortable c'est un peu plus long
c'est surtout très abordable n'a pas
relevé de prix et ça pour moi cette
technologie et ne montre que on y est là
on y est et c'est que le début c'est que
le début mon nom mais on est nombreux
on est nombreux c'est plus qu'une bulle
on est nombreux rien pour une
application comme beurre c'est un
million et demi de français mais si vous
prenez tout l'écosystème et il y en a
énormément des offres sont plusieurs
millions de français aujourd'hui qu'ils
utilisent ça ne s'est pas vous c'est pas
vous c'était le voisin peut-être votre
cousin c'est peut-être cet ami qui est
toujours pas le permis de conduire est
là qui vous dit bon à il est temps là
étant tout bougeait un peu quoi mais au
fond cet ami qui n'a pas de permis de
conduire regardons de plus près est ce
qu'il est vraiment moins livre que vous
est ce qu'il est vraiment moins les
prouesses qui fait vraiment moins de
choses que vous cet ami est ce que en
fait sa vraie chance c'est que est en
fait les livres parce qu'il n'est pas
piégé par ses émotions ses
conditionnements que nous on a créé avec
nos premiers rapports avec notre voiture
lui l'a pas connu la satisfaction de
tenir ce volant la première fois quand
il a conduit sa première voiture il a
pas connu l'émotion d'avoir ses
premières clés du coup mais finalement
il est peut-être plus livre alors dès
qu'on parle de permis de conduire moi ce
qu'on dit souvent c'est vrai ça mais
honnêtement c'est surtout pour les
centres villes c'est vrai au début
c'était surtout pour le centre ville ça
c'était la carte de notre couverture en
2012 aujourd'hui ça a beaucoup de
pouvoir vous donner l'exemple de paris
dans un rayon de 80 kilomètres que ça va
le servir
récemment j'étais à bruxelles je rentre
en thalys je reçois un texto de ma femme
je vous le téléphone je regarde
l'application il ya quatre voitures à
moins de 8 minutes de ma position je
suis dans la banlieue de compiègne à 80
km de paris
alors il ya aussi un petit côté un peu
rassurant j'ai 100 elles sont là ses
clés on sait jamais 2 si je dois partir
là ici maintenant mais je peux ça je
comprends très bien
sam besoin de contrôler
et j'ai un peu changé d'avis par rapport
à ce besoin de contrôler depuis
l'excellent mon frère on est en mars
il vit à londres on est dans la nuit et
là un accident domestique un peu m
toujours est-il qu'il perd beaucoup de
sang au bras tellement de sens que il
est obligé de descendre dans la rue pour
s'assurer que si jamais il tombe dans
les pommes laura quelqu'un pour l'aider
à quelqu'un qui passe fac est regardée
bon sens le fait c'est spectaculaire
il sort son téléphone un clic et
l'emmener en trois minutes aux secours
finalement ça s'est très bien passé
c'est que dizaine de points de suture
mais pas trop visible
c'est plus une grosse frayeur et moi ça
a montré que peut-être que ses clés la
confiance est plus fiable parce qu'elle
sera dure peut-être qu'aujourd'hui elles
nous fournissent un peu moins de liberté
que ce qu'on a là dans notre téléphone
alors là on se dit c'est un peu gros
quand même de se dire est ce qu'on voit
vraiment réussir demain avoir des
centres villes sans voitures
individuelles
c'est vrai que ça paraît un peu gros
quand même et j'ai on a presque du mal à
se le figurer
alors quand un exemple très très près
d'ici je vous demandais de me suivre
on va faire un retour en arrière alors
fermez les yeux vous êtes à strasbourg
dans les années 70 et vous êtes au
volant d'une simca je prends une voiture
qui n'existe plus comme ça y'a pas de
jaloux vous êtes rue des grandes arcades
vous déboulez vous arrivez sur la place
kléber que ce que vous voyez
ouvrez les yeux un parking géant et un
rond point ça c'était la place kléber ya
pas si longtemps que ça
demain on fait la même balade vous
tombez sur une des places les plus
agréables de la ville avec des terrasses
avec des fontaines et surtout en droit
on peut venir s'amuser et passer du bon
temps
moi je suis convaincu qu'aujourd'hui en
fait en 2017 des place kléber on peut en
rajouter des centaines et des milliers
dans tout le pays je convaincu qu'on
peut le faire et c'est à notre portée
alors c'est sûr moi j'arrive un peu avec
mon approche avec mon échelle avec mais
avec mes exemples avec ma vie finalement
et je pense qu'on a tous des
configurations différentes
sachez sûr je suis sûr que dans la salle
n'a objectivement si demain si demain il
n'avait plus de voitures mais
objectivement il pourrait faire moins de
choses et ça je pense qu'on peut le
demander à personne mais on parle de la
liste tout à l'heure la liste de tous
les trajets on se dit tiens aujourd'hui
ça je veux le faire qu'avec ma voiture
moi je reste convaincu que l'art dans
tous ceux qui n'ont pas levé la main si
on refait cette liste maintenant je suis
convaincu qu'en fait avec ça on s'en
tire très bien
on n'a peut-être pas besoin de secret
dans nos poches merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]